qui n'aime pas alors vous rokhaya
chaussée ou m'a rappelé ce week-end elle
était collé qu'est-ce qui se passe
non mais moi j'ai déjà fait plusieurs
fois l'émission de pascale voilà moi
j'aime bien il a participé en débattrons
pouces est important d'avoir des
opinions contrats nature et c'est pas
tant sur le fond que je veux réagir que
soit la forme parce que pascal praud est
un animateur de débat et c'est vrai que
son but est de faire coexister des
opinions contradictoires et le fait d'
interrompre un invité qui vient donner
aucune opinion avec laquelle il est
personnellement contradiction en
réagissant de manière extrêmement
virulent je pense que c'est par son rôle
à son rôle simplement c'est de permettre
aux autres qui ne pense pas la même
chose de s'exprimer et j'ai trouvé que
c'était problématique effectivement
wright a failli partir il est revenu
ouais mais c'est difficile très
difficile de débattre en direct je le
fais beaucoup et on n'a pas besoin
d'être en plus déstabilisée par
l'animateur droit ça que je que je
déplore un petit peu alors vous vous
n'aimez pas quoi en fait non ce qui est
ce qui me gêne c'est qu'il est je te
regarderai que son image en fait je le
trouve un peu trop virulent mais je
pense que il avait un point de vue et
est le fait de défendre si on peut pas
vraiment savoir si c'est parce que
c'était le racisme c'est parce que c'est
le foot si tu veux et le geste en
arrivera et condamnable au possible mais
je peux comprendre que effectivement si
à longueur de temps tu veux juste faire
ton truc faire ton foot et jouets etc à
longueur de temps le balance de ban
raciste ouais il va y avoir une femme je
peux comprendre étant un excellent
[ __ ] pour moi je trouve sa réaction à
base de paix simple on me l'avait dit le
temps alors attendez attendez le
délirant domine une pub et appelons
maintenant sur le coup pied de favori
après ses bras qui arrive dans un
instant il ya le scoop de maxime gagné
louis alors moi d'abord je voudrais dire
donc je me suis beaucoup renseigné sur
cette affaire je voudrais dire d'abord
petit 1 qu'il n'a pas reçu des insultes
racistes
patrick evra donc ça c'est de la merde
donc non mais c'est le point de départ
de monsieur l'antagonisme entre les deux
donc d'abord il n'y a pas eu il n'y a
pas eu d'attaqués racistes et d' insulte
raciste ça a été de l'avis de tout le
monde ça veut dire des virages des
supporters de tout le monde et policiers
de tous les témoins et les stadiers
petit ça on peut le croire aussi donc ça
évidemment on le croit ensuite c'est
très mal connaître marseille ou la
sociologie de marcel pour savoir qu'il
ya absolument jamais d'insultés racistes
ces vraies causes et le terrain
marseille fanni
donc en fait c'est non recevable et moi
je pense qu'en fait c'est plus et vrac a
pété un plomb
parce que c'est la fin de la carrière
d'un joueur qui a été un immense joueur
c'était aussi le désastre de nice nice a
été un immense joie
a manchester united et émission de foot
c'est vrai c'est la fin c'est la fin
merci que c'est la fin d'un joueur s'est
passé c'est pas ça ne s'est pas de
savons qu'on parle qu'on n'aimait pas ça
mais je parle pas là des choses là je
parle de pascal praud voilà c'est
simplement ce que ce que je comprends
pas c'est l'autre fois je l'avais vu
s'énerver c'était contre quelqu'un de la
mairie de paris
seulement le problème c'est que là le
cursan il est passé de 2 1 à 10 c'est à
dire que le mec s'énerve d'un seul comme
ça oui non mais là c'est trop excessif
et comme la semaine dernière nous l'a
déjà fait ou on al'impression sadi un
procédé dans la vie oui mais par exemple
le sanguins et une épreuve qu'il pouvait
très bien dire arrose ceux qui n'étaient
pas d'accord sur son point de vue en
tout cas que la raison c'était racisme
du coup de sang de patrice evra mais par
contre vous pouvez dire plus calmement
la cia au salon reçoit rien moi je suis
d'agression jambes moi ce que je demande
d'un animateur c'est qu'on s'emmerde pas
en regardant l'émission dans le scotch
et on s'emmerde pas voilà son fils moi
je la regarde elle parle pas elle fait
des brushings a fait des coiffeurs je
suis content vous n'avez pas pourquoi
non moi j'aime pas parce que en fait
c'est vrai c'est pas son rôle ou
malheureusement voilà il ya julien
pasquet qui étaient autour de la table
et qui était un peu gêné il pouvait pas
justement l'empêchait de pousser son
côté elle parce que c'est pas
l'animateur après faut savoir que
effectivement parce qu'elle produit n'en
est pas à son premier al ahly mateur
anime la donne son avis témoin cette
fois et chérie on va pas réagir ce qu
est ce que vous aimez paix est pas de
mon de ma part et je pense qu'on a
d'autres choses à faire
vous aimez ou vous n'aimez pas le
choquer je n'en pas choquer certains
titres royaux